hi guys i'm jessica lugo
and this is celebrity recipe royale i'm
gonna be testing out
four celebrity apple pie recipes to find
out
which one is actually the best on
today's lineup
we have lauren conrad andre 3000
claire saffits and asap ferg so which
celebrity has the best apple pie recipe
let's get slicing lauren conrad starts
by making her caramel sauce
she melts the butter adds in flour water
and sugar
and brings it to a boil to create a
paste then she peels
eight granny smith apples chops it all
up
adds in flour brown sugar oh wait my
bowl's too small
we need a bigger bowl that's better
cinnamon
and white sugar
then she takes her pre-made dough and
fills in her pie sheet
she then throws in all the apples into
her pie crust and tops it off with her
caramel sauce
then she takes her second pre-made press
cuts and x at the top
and tops off the pie she whisks together
an egg
washes the top of her crust and adds in
that sugar
and there you have it lauren conrad's
apple pie recipe
mmm okay it looks nice the crust is
quite brown but it doesn't bother me
it looks like something maybe martha
stewart would make
the cinnamon looks on point i'm ready to
eat it
[Music]
i think this is very good oh that's good
very full
of apples it's like in every bite you'll
get like a huge
apple blast in your mouth i would
definitely recommend this recipe
to friends maybe even to my mom my mom
makes good apple pie too
i think it has like a lot of spices it
tastes nice yeah i have no complaints
i also think it's interesting how
chopped the apples are in here
the consistency is really good the crust
isn't too
doughy this is good i don't know what
else to say
next up is andre 3000 he starts off by
popping open a can of pre-made biscuits
we separate them into four portions and
roll them out flat
he then takes applesauce yes i set it
applesauce and smears it to one side of
the dough
he then folds it like an empanada or
calzone
and uses a fork to press down the sides
last but not least he takes butter and
smears it over the top
and adds a little bit of salt then he
bakes it to light golden brown
and there you have it andre 3000's quick
little apple pie
what is this it looks like a calzone i'm
nervous
this looks just like a mega sized apple
pie hand pie
i'm open-minded i'll give it a try
okay this one's interesting it's fine
the filling
it's just like clear gel definitely like
apple sauce inside
this is pop biscuits with apple sauce in
it
if i had to rate it out of 10 i'd
probably give it like a
three or four if i had like a side of
jam it would be good but otherwise i'm
not
too crazy about this one next up claire
sabbats
claire savas starts off by peeling and
coring her apples
bear with me guys this is a long recipe
then she cuts the apples into pieces
yeah i'm still cutting up apples here
she then adds sugar
cinnamon brown sugar and tosses it all
together
then she flowers her counter and rolls
out two pieces of dough that she made
the night before
she places both pieces on parchment
paper and puts it right into the fridge
she places apple cider into a medium
saucepan scrapes in the seeds of a
vanilla bean and throws in the pod
brings it to a boil to reduce it to two
thirds and then adds in the juice from
the apples she had set aside
then she removes the vanilla bean pod
and on the side stirs in corn starch
into
three tablespoons of water throws it
into the mixture
mixes it together until it forms a paste
then she adds the paste
back into the apples then she takes her
first pie crust
cuts off the excess dough and does a
quick egg wash
on the sides of the pie then she places
her apple pie mixture
into the pie crust and then claire puts
dollops of butter along the top of the
apples
then she takes the final pie crust and
places it on her pie dish
and does a quick egg wash off the top
this pie is going to get messy so she
places it
on a baking sheet that's covered with
aluminum foil and then she places her
pie into the oven and bakes it for two
hours we're in quarantine guys
you guys got time and there you have it
claire savitz
deep dish apple pie okay we're back on
track with this one
this is nice and brown lots of apple
slices inside
the crust is very beautiful it has
layers
you can definitely tell it's homemade i
feel like there's something a little
extra that could be added to it
maybe it just needs to be heated up and
it would taste better this feels like
the first pie but elevated this feels
like a fancier version
maybe a little too much cinnamon but i
don't hate it
i think it's a solid pie and now
for the most unique asap ferg he starts
off
quite normal with cutting and coring his
apples
then he chops up his apples and here's
where it gets interesting
he removes the cream from the oreo
cookie and separates them into bowls
he then makes one layer of crumbled
cookies into the baking pan
he then makes a second layer of chopped
apples he then makes one solid layer
of the oreo cookies another layer of
chopped apples
sprinkle some cinnamon on top and
finishes it off with another layer
of cookies and cinnamon he then pops the
dish into the microwave for 10 minutes
once out of the microwave he takes the
remaining cream from the cookies
and spreads it over the top but wait
there's more
he takes strawberry jam and spreads it
all over the top
of the final layer and right before
serving he pops it back into the
microwave for 10 seconds
there you have it asap fergs cookie
apple pie
i don't know what's going on here oh oh
okay it's definitely some sort of pie
crumble mixed together i feel like this
is like some joke you're playing on me
is that chicken is this chicken
apples like kind of raw i realize now
these white pieces is just the oreo
cream
yeah i don't hate it i still think this
is better than the calzone
this is like straight up drunk food you
just threw all your
in something and made a dessert i think
it's still
pretty decent just because all i can
taste is the oreo
i feel like i'm gonna have a cavity
after eating this
so which celebrity has the best apple
pie recipe
let's find out my favorite is definitely
number one
it felt like a classic apple pie it had
a great sugar coating crust
had a lot of dense flavor when you took
a bite classic beauty of course you
would make just like a delicious pie
my favorite is gonna be number three it
was very similar to the first one but it
felt just like
a tad fancier the crust was really nice
it was just a super solid
apple pie that makes sense she's fancy
she knows what she's doing hands down
number one pie
had to be number one the proportions
from
the apple pie to the seasonings the
cinnamon even the sugar
on top it tasted so good
lauren girl that was so good
lauren conrad is the apple pie champion
let us know in the comments which
celebrity or recipes you'd like to see
[Music]
next
you